and finally new role with Valentine's
Day coming up everyone must take a
minute and remember their first love I
sure remember mine I went off to college
at 18 and I fell hard not for a girl
that would have been my first choice but
I was a slow developer socially you know
those letters that college guy send to
Penthouse magazine that begin I never
thought this would happen to me
yeah well that never happened to me but
I did fall I did fall in love with books
and ideas and knowledge and also my hand
that's true but there is no doubt that
it is a truly a kind of love affair when
you go off to a place where you have
intellectual epiphanies because learning
is so revered and the celebrities are
the smartest people I might have been
able to get a [ __ ] in college but I
got my mind blown on a regular basis but
you know that was another country one of
the saddest things about the one we live
in now is we don't seem to want smart
people in our lives anymore smart
president can't have that scientists
what do they know
newspaper editors liars fake news you
know people used to get their news from
newspapers because professional
newsrooms took separating fact from
fiction seriously and employed people
who had studied how to do that but now
people get their news on Facebook by
sharing or as it used to be called
hearsay
instead of all the news that's fit to
print you click on a link from your
cousin Jody who runs the tilt-a-whirl
why waste money on a subscription to a
newspaper when they would just blow it
on war correspondents honor the bend
Bradley's of the world who brought a
president to his knees way before Monica
Lewinsky did pursue a student in a
social media focused group once said if
the news is important it will find me
except it doesn't and that's how we
wound up with President Bannon and his
dummy Donny it's not surprising that it
can't find you since on social media
news competes with videos of Russian car
crashes creepy clowns and a rabbi doing
the mannequin challenge and you know how
they say you can't make this [ __ ] up
turns out you can by Election Day last
year the top fake news on Facebook was
getting more shares clicks and comments
than the real news
millions of people believed some
straight-up [ __ ] that the Pope had
endorsed Trump when in fact after Trump
won what the Pope said was I'm praying
for his enlightenment to which God said
I've done a lot of miracles but give me
a [ __ ] break
[Applause]
we used to respect scientists that's why
every stoner in the 70s had a poster of
Einstein on the wall right next to the
one of the naked black chick with the
huge afro but now only 36% of Americans
say they have a lot of trust that
information from scientists is reliable
well 98% of scientists say humans
evolved over the millennia but that view
is shared by not nearly as many real
Americans Trump supporters don't think
species can change over time but they do
think Trump used to be all about himself
but now he's working for us this
Valentine's Day
can we please fall in love with
knowledge again
you know under President Obama the
Secretary of Energy was first a Nobel
Prize winner and then a nuclear
physicist not that drumstick but the job
doesn't have impressive credentials how
did it happen
we went from being led by the smartest
person in the world to the biggest
jackass on the corner